[Musique]
professeurs étudiants personnels réunis
en assemblée générale ils parlent tous
d'une même voix alors que l'université
de versailles-saint-quentin accuse un
déficit de 4 millions d'euros
le ministère a accordé une rallonge
budgétaire a lui vécu mais les économies
décidées inquiète l'intersyndicale ce
qui nous fait peur c'est devoir payer
l'austérité effectivement pendant 20 ans
et que les solutions qu'on nous propose
pour effectivement on veut rattraper ce
trou est énorme quand même dont on a
pris connaissance assez tardivement
revient effectivement les conditions
d'études des étudiants se traduise à
terme par des licenciements de
personnels contractuels premièrement
s'il ya eu erreur de gestion et ça c'est
évidemment au ministère de le dire c'est
nous qui toujours qui pouvons le savoir
ce n'est pas une raison pour faire payer
aux étudiants et aux personnels ces
heures de gestion passée deuxièmement ce
que nous voulons dire c'est que au delà
des problèmes de gestion locale de
l'université il y a quand même un
contexte de général on ne s'excuse pas
la seule université à être en déficit et
ne sera pas la seule passe en déficit
mais en 2013 dans l'es14 et ça
évidemment là dessus la ministre de
communique beaucoup moins
l'intersyndicale met en cause les
partenariats public privé ils ont été
notamment signé dans le cadre de la
construction de l'ufr des sciences
demandant la dénonciation même pas la
mise à plat la dénonciation puisque ces
partenariats public privé sont
complètement inadaptés à la gestion du
patrimoine
immobilier public tout simplement parce
qu'il nous empêche de planifier et
d'avoir les investissements et de
redonner à la puissance publique le
libre choix de ses décisions
l'ensemble des ppp aujourd'hui sont
mauvais pour l'enseignement supérieur et
la recherche et demandons donc à ce que
l'ancien le ministère ed lu vs que à
sortir de son pépé notamment de pvp donc
le pp économies d'énergie et le pvp qui
concerne le bâtiment en médecine à part
bouygues
parmi ceux qui se sont mobilisés en
faveur de ces partenariats valérie
pécresse ancien ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
l'actuel député des yvelines défense
type de contrat tout en pointant du
doigt le manque de formation des
gestionnaires des universités après si
un partenariat est mal négocié si un
partenariat est mal gérée eh bien ça
peut tourner à la catastrophe
6 mais ça n'est pas l'outil lui-même
qu'il faut condamner ce qu'il faut c'est
en amont bien géré les dossiers et ça
nous remet sur la vraie question qui est
est ce qu'il y a dans l'univers c'est
versailles saint quentin suffisamment de
personnel qualifié et suffisamment de
moyens pour permettre à l'université
d'avoir les mots afin de pouvoir
réaliser toutes ses ambitions et à cette
question je pense que malheureusement la
réponse aujourd'hui et et non le
président de l'université jean luc
vestiaire doit présenter son budget à la
mi décembre en attendant
l'intersyndicale appelle à manifester le
12 décembre à 10 heures devant le
rectorat versant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et rose blanche à la main malgré la
pluie un long cortège de 1000 personnes
dans les rues de trappes jusqu'au square
camus ou moussa 14 ans est tombé sous
les balles le 1er mai dernier
un cortège encadré par des membres du
service jeunesse en gilet jaune des
banderoles qui réclame une paix sociale
dignité et émotion le départ a été donné
de la place des merisiers devant la
famille les amis les proches
à leurs côtés des politiques de gauche
comme de droite
pas de discours pas de mot juste une
envie de comprendre pour que cela cesse
vivement qu'on trouve qui a tué ce gosse
on trouvera parce que c'est pas possible
de laisser dans l'irresponsabilité
l'assassinât d'un gamin de 14 ans soit
possible qu'ils ne l'étaient un gamin
doha pourra vraiment moi quand j'ai
appris quand j'ai appris sa mort je le
dis tranquillement malgré mon âge et mon
expérience j'ai pleuré parce que c'était
c'est un petit bonhomme comme on devrait
en avoir tout ce que commencent en or la
vie dans la foule certains collecter des
fonds au profit de la famille pour les
aider à financer les funérailles au mali
si j'ai fait le taux de voir pour le
moins que tout le monde participe mettez
une pièce latta mais on a eu des
personnes qui ont été généreuses qui ont
une idée
et moi aussi j'appelle de tous mes voeux
pour que
ce qu'on vient de vivre ça ne recommence
plus après cette masse servent à quelque
chose
le long cortège a terminé sa marche
square camus douleur d'une famille des
pots de fleurs et un message pour le
petit soldat moussa partie au paradis
recueillement ont demandé pour tous ces
timbres et des initiatives parce que on
voit aujourd'hui tous les trappistes
il n'y a pas des communautaires parce
que tous les temps la pétition aviva
traduit ils sont là la solennité et les
questionnements aussi l enfant du
quartier ne doit pas être mort pour rien
dit certains
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour changer ça
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour les jeunes des
habitantes de camus pas travaille pas
d'emploi si j'ai vraiment à huis clos
donc j'espère que l'électrochoc aura
lieu finalement rares électrochoc et que
ça changera avec ça bougera tu peux
mettre la police tu peux mettre des
hélicoptères tu me mettre puisque que ça
n'arrangera pas le vivre ensemble
comment d'un quartier à l'autre qu'on se
respecte et on se dit bonjour
en traversant la rue voilà il faut faire
des choses ensemble et ça ça se passe
par le sport par la culture le show
croit encore à sa la mort de moussa
restent encore inexpliquées conflit
entre quartiers aux guerres de
territoires sur fond de trafic de
stupéfiants à trappes du score camus et
ailleurs dans la commune il y aura un
avant et un après moussa
[Musique]